cosa sono sti jeans dov'è la tuta o ma
ci vuole tanto a capire che dovete
mettervi la tuta per fare educazione
fisica allora forse non avete capito
educazione fisica è una materia come
tutte le altre mi si è rotto una gamba
ma se vuoi correre lo stesso
50 giri del campo a partire da ora al
ciclo vita la malattia ciclo vai e corre
come tutti i tuoi compagni forza forza a
papa oltre la juke e fatele [ __ ] non
corretta per punizione e vado a 3 giri
in più degli altri
allora se non la smettete di fare casino
si fa subito su incassi fa teoria
ascolta il ciclo avere una volta al mese
cosa sei un alieno che c'erano volta
settimana adesso andiamo tutti fuori e
ci facciamo venti minuti di salto con la
corda vai ma quale freddo si sto
benissimo fuori ma voi due ore in fondo
cosa state facendo una passeggiata
ora si è vista un calo dopo cinque
minuti a 17 anni siete veramente messi
male prossima volta ad essi cooper e non
accetto giustificazioni